think lightly of yourself and deeply of
the world
it is difficult to understand the
universe if you only study one planet
[Music]
perceive that which cannot be seen with
the eye
today is victory over yourself of
yesterday
tomorrow is your victory over lesser men
[Music]
with your spirit open and unconstricted
look at things from a high point of view
[Music]
do not regret what you have done
[Music]
whatever the way the master of strategy
will not appear quickly
[Applause]
[Music]
it may seem difficult at first but all
things are difficult at first
the way of the warrior is resolute
acceptance of
death from one thing no ten thousand
things
[Music]
as you get the rhythm you discern how to
win
[Music]
it is bad for commanders and troopers to
have likes and dislikes
[Music]
pragmatic thinking is essential
[Music]
it is wrong to be inflexible
[Music]
both in fighting and in everyday life be
determined through staying calm
[Music]
do not let the enemy see your spirit
do nothing that is of no use
[Music]
you may abandon your own body but you
must preserve your honor
[Music]
step by step walk the thousand mile road
[Music]
develop intuitive judgment and
understanding for everything
[Music]
become acquainted with every art
do not let yourself be guided by
feelings of lust or love
i live by choice not by chance
[Music]
do not let the body be dragged along by
the mind
or the mind be dragged along by the body
[Music]
get beyond love and grief exist for the
good of man
[Music]
respect buddha and the gods without
counting on their help
you must understand that there is more
than one path to the top of the mountain
if you know the way broadly you will see
it in everything
[Music]
if there isn't discipline how can there
be a true realization of an ideal
[Music]
truth is not what you want it to be
it is what it is and you must bend to
its power
or live a lie
[Music]
one 000 days of lessons for discipline
10 000 days of lessons for mastery
[Music]
in battle if you make your opponent
flinch you have already won
you can only fight the way you practice
if you do not control the enemy the
enemy will control you
[Music]
the important thing in strategy is to
suppress the enemy's useful actions
but allow his useless actions
the only reason a warrior is alive is to
fight
and the only reason a warrior fights is
to win
to become the enemy see yourself as the
enemy of the enemy
know your enemy know his sword
when your opponent is hurrying
recklessly you must act contrarily and
keep calm
you must not be influenced by the
opponent
[Music]
one must make the warrior walk his
everyday walk
[Music]
in strategy it is important to see
distant things as if they were close
and to take a distant view of close
things
[Music]
in strategy it is necessary to treat
training as part of normal life with
your spirit unchanging
[Music]
the purpose of today's training is to
defeat yesterday's understanding
[Music]
study strategy over the years and
achieve the spirit of the warrior
[Music]
the path that leads to truth is littered
with the bodies of the ignorant
[Music]
you win battles by knowing the enemy's
timing
and by using timing that the enemy does
not anticipate
[Music]
in time all things work to your
advantage when you pursue them with an
open heart
[Music]
if you do not look at things on a large
scale
it will be difficult to master strategy
[Music]
even if a man has no natural ability
he can be a warrior
[Music]
there are many ways of understanding
simple ideas
but generally the opposite is true of
difficult ideas
[Music]
when you attack the enemy your spirit
must go to the extent of pulling the
stakes out of the wall and using them as
spears and halberds
[Music]
it is bad to repeat the same thing
several times when fighting the enemy
[Music]
do not collect weapons or practice with
weapons beyond what is useful
[Music]
no man is invincible therefore no man
can fully understand that which would
make him invincible
[Music]
polish your wisdom learn public justice
distinguish between good and evil study
the ways of different arts one by one
[Music]
it is better to be a warrior in a garden
than to be a gardener in a war
of course the void does not exist
by knowing what does exist you can know
that which does not exist that is the
void
[Music]
if you are not progressing along the
true way a slight twist in the mind can
become a major twist
this must be pondered well
[Music]
what is essential is to think that
anything you are doing may be eliminated
you must examine this well
[Music]
the warrior is the two-fold way of pen
and sword and he should have a taste for
both
[Music]
all men are the same except for their
belief in their own selves
regardless of what others may think of
them
a man cannot understand the art he is
studying if he only looks for the end
result without taking the time to delve
deeply into the reasoning behind the
study
[Music]
it is difficult to realize the true way
just through sword fencing
know the smallest things and the biggest
things the shallowest things and the
deepest things
[Music]
foreign